dos momentos detuvieron Por un instante
la jornada electoral en Brasil los
candidatos Para ocupar el Palacio de
plan alto ejercieron su derecho al voto
Poco después de la apertura de los
colegios electorales el actual
presidente y candidato Yahir bolsonaro
Fue uno de los primeros en votar
vistiendo una verde amarela el
mandatario sufragó en Río de Janeiro
a su salida bolsonaro saludo a sus
seguidores y especuló sobre los
resultados la expectativa es una
victoria para el bien de Brasil hemos
tenido buenas noticias en los últimos
días si Dios quiere saldremos
victoriosos por la tarde o mejor dicho
Brasil saldrá victorioso por la tarde
horas más tarde el candidato y ex jefe
de estado Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
llegó a sufragar en un colegio electoral
de Sao Pablo al finalizar el proceso
Lula rodeado de sus afines políticos
sostuvo un encuentro más formal con la
prensa la verdad
un modelo de vida
el pueblo está definiendo hoy el modelo
de vida que quiere
me coloqué por eso es el día más
importante de mi vida porque hoy me
presento como candidato Y estoy
convencido de que el pueblo brasileño
votará por un proyecto en el que ganará
la democracia
democracia
al finalizar sus declaraciones Luis
Ignacio Luna da Silva se dio un baño de
masas entre sus seguidores Estas son las
elecciones más polarizadas que ha vivido
la nación suramericana desde su Retorno
a la democracia más de 150 millones de
ciudadanos están llamados a las urnas
bolsonaro Ha lanzado continuos
cuestionamientos contra el sistema de
Voto electrónico afirmaciones que ha
hecho sin pruebas y que avivan los
temores de que no reconozca una eventual
victoria de su contri